we know that to tackle the current
climate crisis we need strong Global
ambition and stronger Global action
that is why we continue to call on the
world's largest economies who have that
the means and resources to implement
Green Solutions
to come together and discuss how we can
collectively take steps to address this
challenge at today's meeting President
Biden announced that the United States
will work toward limiting the rise in
temperatures including
putting the power sector on a path to
net zero emissions reducing emissions
and fossil fuel used by accelerating
zero emission vehicle deployment and
decarbonizing international shipping the
President also announced significant new
steps the United States is taking to
support developing countries and taking
stronger climate action including
providing one billion dollars to the
green climate fund and requesting 500
million dollars over the next five years
from Congress for the Amazon fund and
related activities and tomorrow ahead of
Earth Day President Biden will announce
additional actions to advance
environmental justice and protect
communities from the health and
environmental impacts of climate change
he'll also highlight how speaker
McCarthy's extreme Maga agenda would be
a disaster for American families killing
all the manufacturing jobs created
thanks to the inflation reduction act
letting China out-compete us built by us
building the future of clean energy and
making it easier for big corporations to
pollute the air that we breathe
we'll have more to share on tomorrow's
event soon but while I'm on the topic of
speaker McCarthy I have more to say
as you all know yesterday speaker
McCarthy unveiled his plan to cut
benefits for American veterans and take
a two by four to America's manufacturing
resurgence
Not only would the speaker's proposal
cut funding for our veterans it would
repeal the inflation reduction acts
investment in manufacturing in clean
energy Investments that have created 100
000 manufacturing jobs many of them in
republican-led States and congressional
districts
the speaker's plan raises crucial
questions for dozens dozens of House
Republicans
will they vote to kill manufacturing
jobs in their own home districts and
reverse the reassuring of manufacturing
from China and will they vote to cut
benefits for veterans in their own
districts will congresswoman majority
majority Taylor green
vote to eliminate the Investments
helping to create 2 500 solar
manufacturing jobs in her district will
Congress and Mike Carey risk the more
than 2 000 Electric electrical vehicle
investment
related jobs coming to his district
which Republican members of Congress
will back McCarthy's plan to cut
benefits to veterans in their districts
President Biden has fought to create
American manufacturing jobs and ensure
our veterans get the respect and the
benefits they earned and he'll keep
fighting for them
even as republicans in Congress put
forward these proposals to cut jobs and
benefits so the super wealthy and big
corporations can enjoy a tax welfare
now on the other side of Capitol Hill
this afternoon acting secretary Julie
Sue had her hearing in front of the
Senate help committee we are working
hard for every vote and feel confident
about Julie's confirmation she has a
proven track record of working across
the aisle sitting down with the business
community and organized labor and
delivering strong results for the
American economy
that's why Julie was unanimously
supported in her confirmation vote as
deputy secretary of Labor by all Senate
Democrats and that's why Julie's
nomination has been endorsed by a range
of business groups from small business
majority to the LA Chambers of Commerce
and labor leaders from the United Mine
Workers to nabtu and Luna to IBEW she
served as secretary's Walsh right hand
for the last two years as they helped
produce historic
job growth and built strong
relationships with both unions and
employers as well
I also want to say a word about the
decision yesterday made by the Florida
Board of Education to expand the state's
dystopian don't say gay law
as this measure takes effect it will
prohibit all students up to seniors in
high school from learning about our
learning about or discussing lgbtqi plus
people in the classrooms teachers in
Florida have already faced the
devastating consequences of the existing
law under threat of having their
licenses revoked gay teachers have been
forced to take down pictures of their
spouses from their desks and censor
their classroom materials
censoring our classes is not how public
education is supposed to work in a free
country
conservative politicians love to
complain about the so-called cancel
culture all while threatening teachers
with losing their jobs if they teach
something that the Maga extremists don't
agree with
President Biden believes teachers and
students should not be Pawns in a
political game or a political stunt
we will continue to fight for students
across the country to receive a
world-class education including free
from discrimination and also censorship
and finally I want to speak to something
else that urgently needs addressing in
our schools which is gun violence
24 years ago today at Columbine High
School 12 students and the teacher were
gunned down
their lives ripped away in what was at
the time the deadliest school shooting
in American history
the massacre took shook the nation
and it should have been our last school
shooting
instead
in the near quarter Century that has
flow followed hundreds of thousands of
American students have experienced gun
violence in schools
in the United States the number one
cause of death for children is firearms
let me say that again the number one
cause to Children is firearms in the
United States
this is a choice
if republicans in Congress come to the
table if they were to come to the table
we can take action to end the epidemic
of gun violence as we know it
the president is doing his job he
enacted the most significant gun safety
legislation in nearly 30 years and he
has accomplished more through executive
action to reduce gun violence than any
other president in history
state legislators are doing their jobs
yesterday we saw in the state of
Washington legislative legislature
passed and assault weapons ban Common
Sense measures are advancing in states
such as Colorado and Michigan Congress
must do its job ban assault weapons and
high capacity magazine require safe
storage of firearms require background
checks for all gun sales eliminate gun
manufacturers immunity for liability
we must move this country forward so
that tragedies such as Columbine
are forced into history books forever
and our nation's children can live
without threat or fear of gun violence
all right finally thank you for your
patience and bearing with me I would
like to welcome Admiral Kirby the NSC
colleague to the podium he's going to
preview the president's bilat today with
President Petro of Colombia and answer
any other foreign policy questions that
you may have Admiral the podium is yours
anybody
as uh crane mentioned President Biden's
looking forward now to welcoming
president Petro of Columbia to the white
house this afternoon in fact just about
an hour from now
Colombia I think as you know is a
country the president has often referred
to as the Keystone to the region because
it is a country that is emblematic of
the optimism and the potential of the
Americas and one that has over more than
three decades been characterized by
strong bipartisan support here in the
United States
the United States Columbia relationship
is a true partnership that spans trade
where we actually remain Colombia's
largest trade and investment partner but
covers a wide spectrum of other issues
that address our shared Regional
migration challenge combating
transnational criminal organizations
trafficking drugs and of course people
we are aligned in our ambition to
address climate change and we're working
closely with Columbia to expand private
sector investment in renewable energy
the United States is proud to support
implementation of the ethnic chapter of
the 2016 peace Accord between the
Colombian government and the
Revolutionary armed forces of Colombia
otherwise known as the farc
it's emblematic of our commitment to
ensure equal access to opportunity and
to promote prosperity in some of the
communities that are most affected by
violence
Colombia and Colombia's future their
security their prosperity remains a
national security interest of the United
States and during the conversation today
President Biden and president Petro will
continue to make progress on these and
many other issues I also want to note
just a couple of other things you
probably saw readout that we issued the
president had a chance to talk to pres
the European commission president
president
Ursula vondoline they talked about her
recent trip to Beijing president was
interested in her perspectives being
over there they certainly talked about
the need to maintain peace and security
uh around and across the Taiwan Strait
certainly they talked about ongoing
support for Ukraine and the fight
against Russian aggression and again
they talked about how we can together
continue to work with our European
partners for a clean energy transition
president will also have a conversation
later this afternoon with President
macron of France he looks forward to
that and we'll have a readout for you
when that's complete for that take some
questions
cream thank you so John thank you for
being here I want to start off by asking
you about Sudan's decision to send U.S
troops there to update us on the status
of the embassy and trying to get the U.S
officials
yeah so obviously we're still very
concerned about the the violence there
that continued fighting there was a
so-called ceasefire last night that
didn't didn't hold very long and so
people are still being hurt
um and uh what I can tell you is that we
have good accountability of all our
government personnel there working in uh
and out of the embassy they are an
all-not still co-located so the state
department is still the embassy they're
still trying to get them all co-located
together for their own safety they are
still Sheltering in place where they are
um and as you probably saw the Pentagon
did announce that they are moving
forward to pre-position some military
forces and capabilities nearby just for
contingency purposes in case they would
be needed for any kind of uh evacuation
but again no decision has been made on
that the Focus right now is on urging
both sides to stop this violence to
abide by a ceasefire to allow
humanitarian Aid to get to people that
are that are that need it I mean there's
already shortage of food there's concern
over shortages of medicine and water The
Situation's dire in cartoon and we
continue to urge both sides now to stop
this violence for making a final
decision and our sanctions on the table
again
I won't get ahead of any sanctions
decisions I mean we'll always look at a
range of tools and capabilities that we
have to try to to compel both sides here
to stop this violence as for timeline I
think I'd refer you to the Department of
Defense and the state department on that
they would have to work in tandem here
but we want to make sure
that we've got the capability ready in
case it's needed and again DOD can speak
to the timeline on that
[Music]
we're not used to getting the second
question huh
thanks so much
thank you Colleen and thank you John I
have a couple of occasions so security
of President announced that the South
Korea would provide the military aid to
Ukraine if Russia launches the Met is
the attack on the
ukrainians how does the U.S
evaluate this and I forgot that we would
certainly let president Yoon speak to to
um to his comments and to whatever uh
Aid and assistance South Korea would
want to give to Ukraine we were grateful
for the support that South Korea has
already provided Ukraine in the tune of
100 million dollars of humanitarian
assistance and of course they've been
very vocal in support of Ukraine and
they've been very vocal in speaking out
against Russia's uh aggression we're
grateful for that they're a terrific
Ally terrific friend and as I think you
know uh we're very excited to be
welcoming president Yoon to Washington
D.C next week for an official state
visit where I have absolutely no doubt
that they will talk about a range of
challenges not just in the indo-pacific
but across Europe and in Ukraine I mean
weapons to North Korea and the one that
South Korea would pay the price
how do you view Russia threat of
retaliation against the South Korea yeah
look I've seen those comments uh you
know I'll let Mr peskov speak for
himself and speak for uh uh Vladimir
Putin in the in the in the Kremlin here
I would just remind that we have a
treaty alliance with South Korea we take
that commitment very very seriously uh
and uh and I'd leave it at that
thank you John so much for doing this
um the U.S has a lot of recent
experience extracting Embassy Personnel
building Kabul and in key how does this
situation differ or how similar is it to
those and what lessons has the U.S
learned from those experiences that can
be applied here if necessary well I
think just my answer to Kristen I mean
you know if you might recall back in the
uh a couple of months before the
evacuation uh at a cobble the president
ordered the pre-positioning of military
forces nearby so that they could be
ready and they were they were actually
able to get onto the Karzai
International Airport within 48 hours
and within 72 hours basically I had
control of it
um pre-positioning forces is not a new
idea for the U.S military so that they
can be ready you want to be as close as
you can get so that you can close down
that time and space factor it's a
physics problem at that point so you you
can be there as quick as possible so
certainly uh this is an outgrowth of
things we've learned over the last year
year and a half but it's also not
something the military is not used to to
doing it sounds also like it's an
incredibly dangerous environment for
anyone to drive around and be outside
why the decision not to potentially
provide military assistance to U.S
citizens who might need to pay Sudan and
only direct that potential help to
Embassy Personnel the Focus right now is
making sure that we've just got so I
don't know let's not get ahead of where
we are Focus right now is just a
pre-position military forces nearby in
the region in case they're needed no
decision has been made to evacuate
anybody and what we said early on was
that we advised Americans not to travel
it's a cartoon not to travel to Sudan
and we made it clear that
they should be making their way out of
the country
um so I don't want to get ahead of where
we are no decision to evacuate anybody
now has been made it's just really about
pre-positioning military forces if and
when there's a decision to move towards
some sort of military evacuation then
we'll have more to say about that at the
time in term of size scale scope and and
what we're doing but right now the best
thing that can happen is for the
fighting to stop for the two sides to
lay down the arms to abide by these
ceasefires they keep saying they're
committed to and let humanitarian Aid
and assistance food water medicine get
to the people of cartoon who are growing
increasingly desperate for it
thanks Kareem uh John president Petro
came to the White House today saying
that his message on Venezuela is less
sanctions uh more democracy yeah but
Nicholas Maduro uh says that the
sequencing of that has to be sanctions
relief followed by
progress what's the U.S response to it
uh what is the president
we've long been clear that uh that we'll
we would review our sanctions policies
in response to constructive steps by the
Madura regime and if the Venezuelan
parties can make meaningful progress in
return to a democracy in the country
well I think we've also been very very
clear that we're not afraid to take
action should the Maduro regime fail to
negotiate in good faith or to follow
through on its commitments
[Music]
um could you talk about how President
Biden has been involved in this
discussions about Sudan was he briefed
on the deployment the positioning of
these military forces yes he was yes
he's been uh obviously uh following this
very very closely the events uh in
cartoon uh and in Sudan he has been in
touch with his National Security team
regularly since the violence started and
he authorized the military to move
forward with pre-positioning forces and
to develop options in case and I want to
stress right now in case there's a need
for an evacuation and what did the
authorize that today or yesterday
uh this was in the last couple of days
and the same issue
it was John Day the Chinese
give us any update on what he said are
to their plans
I'm refer you to the Chinese authorities
the pla to I'm sorry PRC to uh to speak
to whatever their comments were or how
they phrased it but as Karine noted in
her opening statement I mean that the
Chinese are moving out and moving out
aggressively on a transition to clean
energy and when you look at the
strategic competition that the president
believes that we're in with China and we
do want to keep it on competition and
not conflict this is an area where the
United States can absolutely compete and
win because of the Innovation here in
the United States of America and the
opportunity that we have before us to
really grasp on to a clean energy
transition because there's not only is
that good for the climate it's good for
our economy because it'll mean more jobs
so this is absolutely an area where we
can compete with them now on your first
question
um I I I know of no conversation that we
ever have uh with our allies in the
Republic of Korea where we don't talk
about
um the the threats posed by North Korea
to the into the region and I have no of
no discussion that we have with those
very important allies where we also
don't talk about the challenges posed by
China in the region and globally and I
fully expected that both will be will be
matters of discussion
thank you John
Russia and one of Mexico on Russia there
was a hearing up on the hill yesterday
and we heard from the prosecutor General
from Ukraine and he had asked the United
States to designate the Wagner group as
a foreign terrorist organization does
the White House believe that group
should reach that designation we've made
no such determination and I have nothing
to preview for you on that but
make no mistake this paramilitary
contractor that Mr Putin increasingly
relies upon is certainly
continuing to try to take that move for
one thing and there continue to throw
bodies a lot of prisoner bodies at that
fight
Mr pergosian clearly has some personal
gain here at stake and wanting to take
back move not only for his personal
Prestige and in a way to try to maybe
embarrass the Russian Ministry of
Defense but also for perhaps his own
economic gain since there's a gypsum
mine there not entirely clear but it he
looks like he's got more than one motive
issue of Mexico U.S prosecutors within
the past week here announced the arrest
of 28 members of the Sinaloa cartel and
uh Mexican president amlo described that
as spying and his interference he said
it was abusive arrogant interference
that should not be accepted under any
circumstances I guess what is your
reaction when you hear something like
that and generally speaking how can
us rely on Mexico as a partner in the
fight against the cartels when an arrest
like that is viewed as a negative I'll
certainly let the
president Lopez obrador speak to his
comments uh and and broadly speaking I'd
refer you to the justice department on
this but
the president
had a great discussion uh when Mexico
City with both president Lopez obrador
and prime minister Trudeau about the
need to continue to put pressure on drug
traffickers uh and and the cartels uh
and what you're seeing here out of the
justice department is a step in that
direction here by this Administration
we're going to keep doing that because
it's that important to the Safety and
Security of the American people and
we're also going to keep having these
discussions uh with our counterparts
particularly in Mexico who likewise
suffer from the the activities uh and in
some in some cases uh the unimpeded
activities of these cartels in Mexico
good afternoon
I apologize
I'd like to ask about the the genocide
against the uyghurs in China it's been
declared a genocide by the us as you
well no representative Smith of New
Jersey he just wrote China's president
himself asking to visit xinjiang Smith
says he wants to see for himself what's
going on concerning Mass detention and
forced labor simply what's the
administration's reaction to that
request by the congressman
members of Congress are entitled to
travel where they want and ask questions
of whoever they want we don't take a
position on on their travel just to
follow up on that more broadly speaking
the world promised to never let a
genocide like the Holocaust of World War
II happen again we have a holocaust
museum right down on the street does the
administration believe there's enough
urgency right now in helping the leader
Muslims I think this is the kind of
thing whether it's the uyghurs or
elsewhere around the the world but where
we we have to continue to apply constant
and unrelenting pressure to uh to
protect basic freedom of worship and
human and civil rights around the world
it's not something you can ever let off
on and it's not something that you know
we snap a chalk line and say we're done
and we fixed it and it's over it's the
kind of thing that we're constantly
working at
Japan's our greatest Ally that holds the
largest number of U.S military in any
country in the world and there's a lot
of concern about this recent Spade of
leaks
is
the track from what happened and
Assurance for the future
conversations will be
you're talking about the the documents
that look again uh there's criminal
investigation going on by the justice
department you've seen work out of the
Pentagon to already restrict some access
and they've got the president has asked
uh State Department of Defense and the
Intel Community to take a a broad review
of security protocols practices and
procedures to make sure that they are
appropriate and that we're uh we're not
missing something that that we uh that
we we should have caught but I don't
want to get into speculating about what
happened here all I can tell you is
we're taking this seriously and across
the interagency we're taking steps to
make sure that the protocols and
procedures are appropriate for
um
you
think we left behind for example there's
a Usher oscaria he's an Assyrian uh
there's
we'll have to get out in great Danger
still a large number of people in spite
of the discussions that have not been
able to get out the support of us for
example in spite of the discussions as I
was up here a couple of weeks ago
telling you we're still getting people
out they're still coming out on a
routine regular basis I can't speak for
this particular case there's a process
um and uh that the state department runs
that I would highly encourage anybody
who feels they have a case to be made to
to leave Afghanistan to to still
this is even for Iraq still hasn't been
able to get out again I don't know
anything about that case but when it
comes to Afghanistan because I think
that's what you were asking about we
continue to get people uh out
good
um I said Colombia next week is going to
be hosting an International Conference
on Venezuela to promote talks between
the political forces can you tell us if
the US will be sending a delegation what
type of Delegation yeah look we fully
support this International process as
you know and uh and certainly welcome
the fact that Colombia is hosting it
this time around I don't have a
delegation to announce or speak to today
all right uh follow up on the question
about uh sanctions on Venezuela are
there any concrete conditions or steps
that would for the U.S warrants the
those easing what are you expecting is
there something that you have
communicated that would
lead to an easing extensions without
getting into like a specific menu here
again I go back to what I said before we
want to see concrete steps taken by the
Maduro regime to make good on its
commitments to negotiating good faith
and to help you know transition to a
democracy that the all Venezuelans
deserve
um uh and you know we we have in one
case I think you remember there was a
sanctions relief provided with respect
to Chevron uh down in Venezuela and that
was indicative of again uh our view that
some steps had been taken by the
Missouri regime we'd like to see more
but I I don't think it would be helpful
for me to sit here and give you you know
what the cafeteria list is of all of
those things I mean again we we just in
general want to see the regime move here
in the right direction
Dan Beyond an immediate ceasefire
obviously what is the U.S subjective
what's the preference once the
hostilities if the hostilities end our
preference is to see the the the the
democratically elected civilian
authorities the governor Sudan and the
Sudanese Armed Forces General berhan
says he supports that so we would
continue to urge him to move in that
direction to stop this fighting and and
seek the civilian Authority is the U.S
providing any sort of support or
anything to either side
the sense here that the Americans were
targeted
there's no indication that either side
is deliberately going after or trying to
hurt or Target Americans I can't speak
exactly to what happened in that
instance it's true that uh some some
vehicles of ours came under Fire but
it's not clear that that the people
firing at them knew that it that that it
was a U.S Convoy and again
um there's no indications that Americans
are being specifically targeted but it's
obviously a dangerous situation and
that's a good example of how even if
there's not a deliberate targeting that
somebody could still get hurt or killed
which is why we want these ceasefires to
be observed we want the violence to stop
we want civilian authorities to be
seated so that the people of Sudan can
have a and particularly the people who
live in cartoon can have a peaceful
future
and then a Russia China question
um first of all uh can the two leaders
reconcile their different approaches on
the War on Drugs can the two leaders
the War on Drugs in today's bilateral
and can you tell us a little bit about
how they might go about doing that and
then you said earlier that we're not
afraid to take action should the Madura
regime fail to negotiate in good faith
can you tell us what actions you might
take all I'll tell you is it will
continue to hold any actor that engages
in corruption violates U.S laws abuses
human rights in Venice in Venezuela
we're going to hold them accountable but
I don't have a uh I wouldn't give you a
specific list there and as for uh the
the you quoted the War on Drugs this
effort to go after uh drug trafficking I
mean both president petro and President
Biden agreed it's an issue agree it's a
challenge and they're looking forward to
having that discussion today I fully
expect
um that climate
drugs and certainly migration will be
three big topics that they talk about
today on Russia and China the two
militaries just recent just recently
said they were in a strengthen strategic
cooperation and we're seeing reports
that China is expanding its nuclear
weapons Arsenal with help from Russia
um so is the U.S concerned about these
increase ties between these
will the U.S respond by expanding its
own nuclear Arsenal I'm not going to
talk about the nuclear Arsenal one way
or the other here today we're very
comfortable and confident that we can
continue to protect and defend our
national security across a range of
capabilities and you can look at the
defense budget and see for yourself the
nuclear modernization is something we're
heavily invested in and we know we got
to continue to work on that as for their
relationship we've spoken about this
before too uh that these are uh
obviously two countries that
share opposite values than the United
States and our partners and allies do in
terms of the international order in
terms of peace and stability around the
world they want to challenge that order
they want to undermine that order they
want to rewrite the rules for themselves
and as the president has said we we've
got to consider this a strategic
competition and it's a competition that
we can win
exactly is the so you said that we don't
know for sure what their motivations
were fine but what are we doing to
assure that in the future any
belligerent think 30 times before
attacking a U.S country again I don't
want to talk about that particular issue
too much because I don't I don't know
exactly how it transpired we have
communicated to both sides
directly through diplomatic channels uh
that this violence has got to stop that
we need a ceasefire that everybody can
observe so that the people of cartoon uh
can can move on and we can get a
civilian Authority seated that's the
focus okay my second question I'm going
to kick over to Brian
what
oh thanks all right
uh I guess I'll just follow up on the
leads uh I I like to drill down a little
bit on that
and you said you were going to take a
look at the protocols that led to that
particular person getting the
information
is that include possibility of
sanctioning those who allowed him to get
this information in the first place is
that under consideration because what I
hear out of out of defense is that look
you're going to make a skate gallowed
out of the 21 year old whoever made the
decision is going to get away with it
right well let's be clear what I said
was that the president wanted the Intel
Community DOD in the state department to
take a broad view of security protocols
and practices at large not necessarily
with respect to this particular case I
think you heard that the secretary of
the Air Force is already uh ordered a
specific Air Force review Into the the
unit to which that individual was
assigned and I certainly would let the
Air Force speak to that more
specifically that's willing for them but
do you think that that will be part of
do you anticipate yeah I think you
really got to talk to the Air Force
Brian I mean they're they're taking a
look at that particular unit and that's
really for them to speak to but the
president's direction to the interagency
was take a wide look at protocols and
procedures for for security
classification
appreciate it thanks Admiral sorry guys
we tried to take as many questions as
possible uh but we're running out of
time
McCarthy accusing of a deficiency of
leadership uh what is your response to
those times of Senator mansion and is
your appointment the president's I'm
willingness to negotiate because
so as you know we have a strong and
productive relationship with Senator
manchin he's someone that we have been
able the president has been able to pass
some historic pieces of legislation
because of of uh the help of Senator
Mansion so again they have a strong
relationship the president's message is
pretty simple and has been it has been
very simple this past several weeks
several months the way to have a real
negotiation on the budget is for House
Republicans to take threats of default
when it comes to the economy and what it
could potentially do the economy off the
table we've been very clear about that
he's put forward his budget the
president has said here's my budget he
was very clear he showed his values his
budget is going to decrease the deficit
by an additional three billion dollars
over the next 10 years is going to make
sure that we invest in Americans that we
lower cost so the president has said
here's what I'm going to do and not only
that make sure that the super wealthy
are are paying their share and so are we
look president and Senator manchin agree
we must avoid default and just as
President Reagan said and just as
president Trump said that when they were
in office we have to avoid default that
means House Republicans need to get to
work and stop the delay and put a bill
on the full on the floor that's going to
avoid the vote
um uh at the major economy performance
of countries including the United States
of expanding possible
did you respond to that criticism and
what's his mess is best played for the
Press
look we've been very clear this is a
president this is the fourth time that
we've held this forum uh we believe uh
that is important for these uh that we
need in order to deal with this issue we
need a global collaboration and Global
action and that's what you saw this
President do and make sure that we bring
the world together to deal with an
incredibly important issue like climate
and so the president's going to continue
to do that he's going to continue to
have these conversations I'm not going
to speak directly to every country in
their in their statement and their
comments as the Admiral was being asked
about China specifically but we believe
these have been really important forums
again this is the fourth one since the
president has taken off and we'll
continue to have them the last question
is an IRS special agent wants protection
talk about investigation 100 by taxes
what is the White House's message to
employees you wonder if there should be
political considerations when
uh the president's family so look I want
to be very clear here as you know the
president respects the rule of law and
and the independence of the Department
of Justice he believes that's what they
should be in this Administration we
believe that it should be independent uh
so I'm not going to go beyond that
department of justice will certainly
deal with this issue again he believes
in the rule of law he believes in the
independence of the justice department
put on the investigation but is the
president confident that his attorney
general has upheld all the ethical
obligations here when it comes to this
investigation again the president has
always been clear during the campaign
during his presidency that the
Department of Justice should have
Independence they should not be
politicized and they should be able to
do their job
independently essentially and so I'll
leave it to them I'll leave it to the
Department of Justice to make their
decision to do to uh to move forward
with this particular case we're just not
going to comment from here I I know
actually my colleagues from the White
House counsel's Office actually put out
a statement on this and address this
more more specifically but again I would
refer to the Department of Justice or
anything else on the debt limit what
will it take the president to sit down
and have a face-to-face conversation
with house Speaker McCarthy at this
point to try to hash out some of this so
look I've been very clear when it comes
to uh the debt the debt ceiling sorry
there's something flying around
um that should be done without
conditions that should be done just like
speaker McCarthy himself and other
Republicans when they got together with
Democrats the last uh three times in the
last Administration they should deal
with this this is their constitutional
duty to make that happen as it relates
as it relates to the budget we saw what
uh speaker McCarthy and Maga wing of the
Republican Party put forth which was we
believe is is cruel we we believe which
will be really harm American families
who are struggling every day to make
ends meet that's what what they put
forward their plan their blueprint
that's what it tells us if you look at
the 22 percent Cuts in veterans and
veteran services if you look at how they
want to cut Meals on Wheels they want to
cut law enforcement funding that's what
it shows so we're going to take a look
at it we're going to look at the impacts
of of the plan the blueprint that they
put forth and we appreciate that the
speaker put that to put that together
and look
the president has been very clear uh you
know show me your budget and I'll show
you what you value we have seen what the
republicans in Congress in the house
specifically along with the speaker
speaker McCarthy value and this is what
they put forward yesterday something
that we believe will harm American
families okay
let's go follow up there um
anytime tomorrow if he has his budget he
has now put forward a proposal so will
there be a meeting well I just said
we're going to look at the impact of of
the plan that they put forward we're
going to take a look at it I've said
that already right now what we are what
we see with the 22 percent uh spending
cuts that they put forward is going to
hurt education it's going to hurt
veterans veterans Medical Care Meals on
Wheels food safety so that's what we're
seeing right now but we're going to take
a closer look we're going to analyze
that we appreciate the speaker for
putting this forward but again it
doesn't stop them for acting right away
immediately to put a to put a piece of
legislation on the floor to make sure
that we do not default we should not be
Congress
specifically speaker McCarthy and the
and the right wing the Maga extremist
should not be holding our economy you
know to uh to put forth programs that's
going to hurt American people so again
we're going to analyze what they put
forward to us and we'll have more to
share I'm just saying that one thing
that we know for sure is they need to
make sure that we do not default that is
something republicans in Congress need
to act on now they can do that right
away we're going to look at the impacts
of this blueprint that they put forward
okay so just to follow up on that it
sounds like you're uh saying that
there's a possibility that the president
won't sit down with I'm not saying
speaker I'm not saying that at all I'm
saying we're looking closely at uh at
the uh at the proposal that they put
forward we're going to analyze the
impact of the of the 22 percent uh
spending cuts that they put forward and
but what we are saying at the same time
uh look I don't have a meeting to
announce but we've been very very clear
we need to make sure that we avoid
default we're going to look at the
impact but girls are no longer saying
there will be a meeting at some point
I'm just saying we don't have a meeting
to announce at this time um on another
matter the house passed a bill this
morning that would amend Title IX
definition of sex to be based entirely
on an individual's genetics at Birth
does the White House have a position on
that bill I don't have a position on
that bill but we've been very clear that
the administration is committed to
protecting lgbtqi plus kids at school
that's why last year the Department of
Education proposed a rule to clarify
that lgbtqi plus kids have fundamental
civil rights protections against
discrimination in our nation's schools
last week as as you know the Ed proposed
a rule that helps clarify how those
protections would work in the context of
of the of the Athletics clearly the
education department could could
certainly lay that out more but we
believe that we are committed and we
want to make sure that we're protecting
lgbtqi plus I don't have anything
specific on this particular and on that
topic the transgender actor and
influencer Dylan Mulvaney has been the
target of a barrage of attack from
anti-trans individuals online after she
did an ad with Bud Light a couple of
weeks ago she's someone who has been
here to the White House She interviewed
the president last year he had a lot of
warm Wards for her has anyone here at
the White House reached out to her since
she became the target of these attacks
so don't have any calls to review at
this time and I don't have anything to
say specifically about this report but
what I can say when a transgender
American
supposedly a video about a brand of beer
they enjoy and it and it leads to bomb
threats it's clear that that level of
violence and virtual against transgender
American has to stop and the president
has been very clear I just laid this out
the Administration has uh is going to do
everything that they can to protect
lgbtqi plus people who are under attack
and that's what we've been seeing across
the country especially in state houses
and so we're going to fight alongside
them to protect their rights they should
be allowed to be who they are who they
want to be and they should be able to
speak out against and we should be able
to speak out and others should be able
to speak out against hate and
discrimination but look that type of uh
dangerous rhetoric that type of
vitriolic
language and violence that needs to stop
[Music]
McCarthy just to be very clear for the
sake of transparency which the President
says he values does the White House
support giving this IRS agent disability
for the state of transparency and so
that we do not politicize any of this
the president has been very clear that
this is something for the Department of
Justice which is independent and we have
been very clear since the campaign that
this is something that they need to
speak to and that's why we refer you to
the Department of Justice we're just not
going to speak for to it about it from
here I just have you respond to some
Republicans though who suggest that the
fact
or
[Music]
agent could show that the administration
is
we're letting Department of Justice
handle this that's what that's what an
Administration does when they believe in
the rule of law when they believe that
the Department of Justice is independent
that's what the president believes this
is something for the Department of
Justice this is an issue that they're
dealing with and we leave that to them
as I mentioned my White House colleagues
at the council's office put out uh put
out a statement on this they were more
specific on that and so I certainly
would refer you to to my colleagues and
to the Department of Justice
the debt limit at the risk of dating
here back in 2011
during the day ceiling fight then and do
in part to the gridlock over that issue
s p downgraded the nation's credit
ratings markets plummeted interest rates
increase the country's borrowing costs
went up by more than a billion dollars
president risking the Same by and
Congress by dragging out the president
that's risking this is no it is Congress
it is Congress that is risking this uh
these political stunts that you're
seeing from speaker McCarthy and the
mega Wing this is dangerous these are
political stunts that will have long
lasting effects as you just laid out
this is something that they can easily
deal with immediately by putting a piece
of legislation on the floor to deal with
not defaulting this is their
constitutional Duty we should not have
to negotiate on this we should not be
doing this with conditions they were
able to do this three times under the
last administration of Republican
Administration doesn't everyone bear
responsibility including and especially
yeah
the responsibility to make sure that we
do not default it sits in the hands of
Congress and right now it is Speaker
McCarthy and the mega Wing the mega Wing
part of me of of the Republican
conference it is it is up to them to get
this done they are wasting time and
we've I've already laid out what they
did propose how much that's going to
hurt American families who are trying to
make ends meet but the president said
show me your budget he didn't say show
me a budget
well you have to finish what he said the
the statement that he made his quote is
show me your budget and I'll show you
what you value that's what the president
said and by looking at this print by
looking at the plan they are certainly
showing us their value I guess
I already answered the question Kristen
many many times this is a constitutional
Duty that Congress has and speaker
McCarthy is playing games he's he is
wasting the time of the American people
this is a political stunt and he has to
act he has to act and what he showed us
yesterday he aligned himself with the
Maga wing of the party go ahead okay
just the problem solvers caucus wants
the suspension of the debt limit to be
paired with this creation of a
Commission in
either of some kind of commission that
would
learn spending yeah
I hope we have a very good relationship
with the problem-solving caucus I don't
have anything to say about this specific
matter We believe We believe that it is
up to Congress whatever tools they need
or mechanism they need to move this
forward but again I'm just not going to
comment on any specific mechanism
that you mentioned at the time
it's earlier
so I don't have anything else to add to
the readout there was a readout and so I
will share that the president
will have the opportunity to speak with
the president Mark Hall later today so
there will be a little readout but I'm
just not going to go get ahead of that
conversation and what may be discussed
we'll try to go to the back
following the
rest days with a renewed debate about
so-called like
stand your ground laws quite a number of
experts and activists say that these
laws are actually promote violence fuel
gun violence so what's the
administration taking so what what our
take on this is that Congress needs to
act I laid out at the top of my uh at
the top of the briefing what we have
seen State houses do in some states who
have taken action in Banning assault
assault weapons which we lift up and we
we uh we appreciate but now we need to
see Congressional members or republican
Congressional members take action we
need to see them put forth Common Sense
Common Sense laws when it relate as it
relates to gun as guns and so we need to
see that type of Reform we need to stop
what we're seeing this epidemic of gun
violence across our country in our
schools in our churches in grocery
stores we have to do everything that we
can to stop this is a president who's
taken action over and over again he's
taken historic action taking uh doing
putting forth executive actions in the
first two years more than any other
president and so what we're saying and
we're going to be very clear the
president's going to use his bully
pulpit to continue to to pressure
Congress to take action that's what we
need that's what the American people
deserve that's what our kids deserve
that's what our communities deserve and
that's what we're going to continue to
call for I'm going to continue to go
back to that Phil thank you we've got
two quick questions the president ended
the coveted emergency earlier this month
and one of the things that House
Republicans are calling for is for some
of the unspent pandemic emergency
funding to the clawed back with the
president I know he has a reputation
during the Obama Administration as being
the sheriff when it comes to rooting out
waste fraud abuse would he at least be
interested in reviewing whether there is
some of that money that could be
returned to treasury I mean look here's
the thing what the president has been
able to do in this first two years of
this Administration is deal with a
pandemic a once in a generation pandemic
by putting forth a comprehensive plan
you think about the American Rescue plan
what it was able to do no Republican
voted for that and so
we use that money to actually be in a
different place than we are today covet
is not over but we are in a different
place and so it is uh it is bizarre
after the progress that we have seen for
Republicans to be asking this but we we
the president when he came in nothing
was being done
he made sure that our he made sure that
economy came back came back in a way
that uh that it was that we haven't seen
in some time by by making sure we
created more than 12 million jobs he
made sure that people had shots and arms
he made sure that we were to come out of
this pandemic again covet is not over
but we are certainly in a different
place than we are we have been before
because of what the president has done
and the action that he took and so to
say to claw back money uh after having
having the successes that we have seen
because of this president's action it
just doesn't make sense to me I got to
keep going I okay yeah okay go ahead go
ahead um you know want to follow up on
the White House's proposal to mandate
that two-thirds of all passenger
vehicles by the year of 2032 be Electric
it's a lot of batteries obviously so
does the administration have a concrete
plan to ensure that those raw materials
for these new EVS either through Federal
support or some type some type of
motivation for the private sector that
those EVS don't end up coming from China
and we don't become dependent on a
foreign power that might not be friendly
to us so here's what I can say every
step that the president has taken is to
build more here in America that's every
step that he's taken to bring
Investments and jobs back to America to
build Supply chains here in America and
that's what's happening and already the
private sector has invested more than
120 billion million billion dollars to
build more electric cars and batteries
here in America and that is because that
is what the president has wanted to do
and put forth and he wants to make sure
right we are building here right here in
in the United States I'm going to keep
going I'm going to keep going I'm trying
to call someone I have go ahead Alex in
the back go ahead
there's been a devastating gas shortage
of Bruno santis and other Florida
lawmakers to alleviate that and to make
sure
[Music]
we're closely monitoring the situation
in Florida right now and our
Administration has been in touch with
the state to offer assistance the EPA is
quickly processing a request it received
from the state today to expand the
available supply of gas in the region
and so we stand ready to to do the same
for any additional request assistance
that comes from the states or that the
state makes and so again we're
monitoring we are offering assistance
and then let me just continue to go
around
part of the meeting but are there
conversations taking place at this point
between White House staff and house
leadership staff house Republican
leadership I've said this before we have
been in constant communication that is
that is still continuing we have been in
constant communication as a president's
Direction with with house leadership
from many many weeks now for months now
and so of course that's continuing any
reaction to this SpaceX Starship rocket
that exploded after launch today so I
saw those reports I don't have any I
don't have a reaction at this time
Senator Durbin has said that they're
going to ask Chief Justice John Roberts
to come testify about judicial ethics
does the White House think that that
would be a useful thing for the Justice
to go to I'm going to leave that to uh
to Congress to deal with we're not we're
just not going to comment from here top
donors from the president's 2020
campaign been invited to
as it seems like the campaign decision
is approaching at some time can you kind
of lay out how the president plans to
separate uh his role as a political
candidate versus his
team so uh first not going to comment on
on 2024 or potential plans or whatever
is going to happen in 2024 as you know
we follow the Hatch Act here in this
Administration what I will say is that
any announcement or anything that that
is related to 2024 certainly will not
come from here go ahead Michael
basically uh back on the budget one of
the items that house
uh has been marked for the IRS I'm just
wondering how important this is to the
president I know he's talked about it
but how important is it to him is it
something they'd be willing to give up
get a budget deal
again not we're going to look at the
impacts of this blueprint this plan that
that speaker McCarthy and mega
Republicans put forth I'm not going to
speak to specific items in in their in
their plan what I can't say more broadly
the 22 spending cuts is going to hurt
American families think about veterans
you think about Meals on Wheels you
think about education you think about
law enforcement that's going to hurt
everyday families who are trying to make
ends meet not going to go into a
piecemeal of the plan again we're going
to take a look at it and see what the
impacts of the uh it will be to the
American people
I know we have to wrap okay I'll be back
tomorrow I'll be back tomorrow thanks
everybody